now in the first TED movie Seth you you
gave some challenges to mark it was the
famous 57 white-trash girls names yes
which yes that autocue or did no I
learned it we we brought in cue cards
think it because I'm thinking to myself
oh man I could never learn this [__]
this is like this is this is a mile of
names and there's no context to kind of
do any kind of Association in your head
and I said you know we have these cards
for you and marks like yeah I think I
got it and just rattles them off take
after take like that I still don't know
how that was accomplished but it's
pretty but this time you gave him
another list of 57 things that's right
but you cut it out how did you know that
he told us I still wake up in the
morning say my [__] names yeah well what
was happening is we were doing a scene
where a tent cuz it was such a great
moment in the movie thought maybe we'll
throw back to it and then or maybe he'll
just make me study this thing for four
months and then I use it but yeah so
it's all these movie names how can you
still do it yeah I can still do that's
all I know I mean I think about the [__]
oh my god can you really be 57 is olla
vader kenobi palpatine calrissian balboa
rambo griswold stepford bickle gump
corleone wonka Sivaji lebowski venkman
spengler stands rizzo zuko like the
higgins dolittle poppins bomb blow for
blow tarski light you associate a hairdo
Frankel so McFly Baggins Plissken of a
territorial burgundy says he has a
driven striker be will elect a part of
Weasley Dumbledore sparrow doubtfire
bourne one translator Kirk Spock McCoy
[__] Khan
[Applause]
[Music]
you with the shin don't be discouraged
when you hear the sound of thunder don't
you get too scared
just grab your Thunder buddies and say
these magic words [__] you Thunder you
can suck my dick